[Musik]
ins kraut machen muss folge hingestellt
das muss über die bewerbungen und das
ist ein riesending für gestalterisch zu
kv ja aber was hat jetzt
wenn die tochter vor der berufswahl
steht kann es krisen geben
eine schnupperlehre ist meist nichts
anderes als eine bewährungsprobe
jugendliche können überfordert sein wenn
es um die große weichenstellung im leben
geht
[Musik]
das ist ein film über john und seine
klassenkameraden während des letzten
schuljahrs
[Musik]
die schüler der 6a klasse 4a im
aargauischen birr stehen am anfang eines
bewegten schuljahres die sommerferien
2010 sind vorbei
[Musik]
lehrerin susanne junk bringt noch etwas
ferienstimmung mit in den
geografieunterricht
[Musik]
hier und dort angewandt und das heißt
einmal beispiel wenn müssten auch
zusammensetzen
nie im leben
die lehrerin hat trotz ihrer autorität
einen guten draht zu ihren schützlingen
also die größten flüsse dh den nil nicht
vergessen den kopf
die hinterste reihe nimmt es gerne etwas
locker alle
länder werden hier war es nur diesen
spielzeugen werden
umständlich und teuer wäre ich glaub
geschafft ist
[Musik]
dann nötig sagen wir steigen in die
pause
john musste einmal eine klasse
wiederholen und ist somit dem zehnten
schuljahr er gilt als schwieriger
schüler susanne jumper redet ihm einmal
mehr ins gewissen
und da war doch ausmachen sind so
selbstverständlichkeit aufgabe machen
und pünktlich der
städtischen sich dessen bewusst dass du
dich hoffe man gerade befindet
hand drauf
egal wie sie zu heute in einer woche
wieder die haare
und den bilanzen
die suche nach einer lehrstelle als
grafiker ist für john eine mühselige
angelegenheit
bisher reitzig absage an absage um seine
chancen zu vergrößern bewirbt er sich
auch als detailhandels verkäufer doch
das ist für ihn keine
herzensangelegenheit
dementsprechend hält sich seine
motivation in grenzen mit dem sieg schon
jetzt wieder mit meiner kollegin kann
ich jede summe fehle man kann klären
also man kann das jetzt zwei jahre
und das loch schieben parallel zu und
bewerte ich schriebe gar nicht im grab
aber wenn ich mal
kritisch hocken das macht dann lange die
larven oder dann die serie konzentriert
das meinen befehl musik lassen aufgaben
machen und lehrern naja also na ja so
dass ich auch für mich eine
beschäftigung also wann bild online und
weiß man wer schicken ihr
workout
zur gleichen zeit im wohnzimmer neben an
john stiefvater zur an sechs schaut sich
eine dvd an
wer es ist einfach fantastisch wenn sie
das gesamte
die aufzeichnung zeigt eine
massenveranstaltung einer ungarischen
freikirche bei der auch der kroate
mitglied ist immer wieder macht mich
richtig leidenschaftlich das macht mich
das begeistert mich
christliche werte will zu rang sechs auf
seinem stiefsohn vermitteln und dazu
auch eine anleitung zu beruflichen
erfolg
was ich liebe
klasse also brandenburg georg georg der
student das aber nicht nur dem buch da
er weiß was er will und was nicht lang
zu gott die schule zu ende und du
solltest lehrstelle haben also von dem
her die sand wohl auf die drei wichtige
frage was macht ihr was macht mir echte
freude wo liegen meine einzigartigen
stärken was will ich in meinem leben
erreichen du das immer wieder dieselbe
frage und
ja drauf libertäre es auch ist sicher
interessant ist dies auch mit der
lehrstelle prozess hat zu einem
schweizer musiker
[Musik]
nächster halt ist mit dem stiefvater
also ganz hell und offen gesagt
ich also beste comedy zum teil sind für
den sachen ok wurf mich ebenso ok sind
er bemisst sich zum teil als vermisst -
persönlicher privatlabore dass das das
finde ich dass wir jetzt haben wir
haben es jeweils ist die ganze familie
beisammen
johns mutter so elmar seck arbeitet als
kunden assistentin in einer bank die
gebürtige brasilianerin ist für den
familienunterhalt zuständig die ehe man
verdient als zeitungsverträger ein
zubrot die beiden fordern den
16-jährigen auf sich bei der
lehrstellensuche mehr anzustrengen
nach einer woche fehlt die
co2 bewegung macht
die dinge gut und deutschland führt aus
und ich sind mal ausprobieren wollten
sprach
das ist aber die sache mit dem potenzial
das ist so klar
bewusst werde überlegt konzil
weniger für
missbrauch und
misshandlung
friedrichstraße nicht gut dran
[Musik]
die 20 schülerinnen und schüler der
sekundarschule 4a haben im
biologieunterricht eine spannende
lektion susanne jumper nimmt das thema
sexual kunde durch
ich frage jetzt nicht die herren aber
wir auf die jagd geht ist ausgerüstet um
das
hat da jemand etwas zu ergänzen
nur ramona homberger erhebt die hand die
klassenbeste weiß auch hier die richtige
antwort
[Musik]
in der schnupperlehre bei einem arzt
ramona fühlt sich wie zuhause
medizinische praxisassistentin ist seit
kindheit ihr traumberuf nicht unter
druck setzen die berufswahl
nicht aus wie ein
schlachtfeld macht das gewinnen können
und müssen
arzt george bourani ist von ramona
begeistert
die bewerbung hat mich sofort
angesprochen
ich habe gesehen dass st
jetzt.de humor und punkto
ausführlichkeit so zimmer das top-niveau
abgefunden
kein wunder ramona kann aus mehreren
angeboten auswählen sie entscheidet sich
für eine lehre in der praxis von joachim
gerbitz in bruck
in begleitung ihrer eltern heinz und
claudia homberger unterzeichnet sie den
vertrag beim spezialisten für innere
medizin
ramona ist die erste schülerin der
sekundarklasse die eine lehrstelle
gefunden hat freust du dich
[Musik]
die anderen sind noch nicht so weit im
deutschunterricht simulieren sie
gesprächssituationen wie sie sich beim
vorstellen in lehrbetrieben begeben
können
[Musik]
programm und hätten pc haben und war mit
meinen kollegen verursacht dann kann sie
mir irgendwas
erlaubnisse ladens gern noch mal zu
hause kann
[Musik]
aber auch eine spezielle betreuung der
von schulsozialarbeiter roche fricke
hält die beiden haben zusammen einen
vertrag ausgehandelt der den schüler
verpflichtet mehr bewerbungen zu
schreiben zudem soll er sich im
unterricht anstrengen doch john ist
schwer zu motivieren
obwohl er damit den rauswurf aus der
schule riskiert der sozialarbeiter will
erfahren woher die null bock stimmung
kommt
es wirklich dass ich verschiebe ich muss
mir eine ehre dass die priorität
es bringt es nicht groß
also wenn du von der schuld der sterne
bewerber also ich immer das fundament
für die bewerber ich versuche jetzt aber
super bilanz die affäre hat theoretisch
könnte geschnuppert
hast es wird langsam wieder an und ich
glaube der erfolg pte die stimmenzähler
die vermieter im vertrag ich glaube
nicht ich glaube weiß nicht ob ich halte
ich glaube das sind die haut ist aber
dort ihr
ups und downs hat gezeigt dass du dir
viel vornimmt und denn plötzlich alt ist
oder es ist wichtig dass man durchaus
halte ich sie mir das ziel ich mir sein
ich weiß es könnte filme bewerbung salon
gut dann machen
der schulsozialarbeiter der lässt es
nicht beim reden
zusammen suchen sie im internet nach
offenen stellen also was für eine brust
hat also für einen
kranich habe das siebenminütige
am 7 ich bin so wichtig nur gegen
hoffenheim als clean chic in bewegung
das ist eigentlich jedes mal
und der begriff fotograf ich besser weg
oder durch einfach dass es
kalt und was ist jetzt habe ich von
ihnen seien in vielen fällen muss
valentino
rossi frank empfiehlt schon sich für
verschiedene berufe zu interessieren
sie finden über ein dutzend adressen von
firmen mit offenen lehrstellen
[Musik]
musikunterricht bei beta ehrensberger
die ballade steht bei den schülern nicht
sehr hoch im kurs
auch saskia rupprecht zeigt wenig
begeisterung was eigentlich erstaunlich
ist
denn singen ist ihr hobby
[Musik]
aber noch lieber würde sie eine berühmte
sängerin werden
casting für die grössten schweizer
talente auch saskia hat sich angemeldet
als moralische unterstützung begleiten
sie freund etienne und ihre mutter
beatrice rupprecht
doch die konkurrenz ist groß weit über
1000 personen wollen wie sie ein star
werden
[Musik]
saskia malt sich bereits ein leben im
rampenlicht aus sie fragt sich ob
mädchen damit umgehen könnte
gc kommt nicht so ein dicker brocken
[Musik]
ihrem wunsch als sängerin karriere zu
machen steht die mutter skeptisch
gegenüber
[Musik]
saskia hat dafür kein offenes ohr sie
will jetzt ihre chance packen
[Musik]
es ist soweit die 16 jährige darf sich
der jury präsentieren die nicht im bild
erscheinen möchte
[Musik]
ein paar wochen später in das glas
zimmer ist die ernüchterung zu gast die
jury der talentshow hat ihr eine absage
erteilt
zwischendurch das lenkrad mit dem
casting
show ja
menschen die nach vielen hof nicht räumt
und auch vorgestellt es fängt sie
[Musik]
john beichtet seiner lehrerin etwas die
polizei erwischte ihn mit einem
gestohlenen fahrrad und
[Musik]
das ist von mir vor es ist seelisch dass
man technologie 40 bringen und das mit
einer lehrstelle halle bringen aber du
musst mit schafft oder in positive sache
machen
im prinzip haben wir ihm die rote karte
zeigte sich nitra und wenn sie jetzt den
männern besetzte fahrzeuge geht voraus
denn 100 punkte zu dass ich
langsam muss kämpfe darum
und mir gott helfe um das eine durch die
straßen das bringt es ohne dass nur
schneller
[Musik]
steht von allen seiten unter druck nur
zu seinem leiblichen vater denn der
selten sieht ist die beziehung locker
der 16 jährige würde am liebsten zu ihm
ziehen
[Musik]
der 47 jährige roger bürgi verdient sein
geld als finanzberater
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich aber für moderne wohnen
ist natürlich noch zwei hauptziele über
eine freundin oder und
technisch schwierig im moment ganz gut
ja ich muss einfach eine neue wohnung
bisher größten vorhaben
ab oder sie gar nicht so schnell
verhüten
[Musik]
und ich brauche schon im bauch
für bauern
du hast du gar nicht mit
[Musik]
kann der dann die situation
nicht ganz ganz hundertprozentig genau
aber ungefähr also ich denke schon dass
er
weiß was es geht ich finde ich einen
typischen das jetzt nicht zum vater
wohnen moment in die knie zwingen
in anderen war gar nicht nehmen ein
indisches einig neben will
gewonnen oder aber es wäre einfach
praktische reduzieren
[Musik]
stefan widmer ist bei seinen mitschülern
beliebt alle so gemütlich ist
er als elektriker machen
[Musik]
er und sein bruder silber spielen gerne
computer games aber eigentlich hätte
stefan noch einiges zu tun für die
schule aber
bewusst dass man nach russischen
machen
hausaufgaben waren der kollegin machen
das ist ein gutes argument um abends
noch etwas aus dem haus zu kommen die
widmer ist eine alleinerziehende mutter
fühlt ihm noch etwas auf den zahn
er darf zur kollegin gehen aber zuvor
muss noch die hasen füttern
gestresst wenn zum gletscher gemeinsames
lernen
aber ich will natürlich lieber mit
kollege durch zum teil
aber
[Musik]
zu lösen die hausaufgaben kommt stefan
an diesem abend nicht mehr
[Musik]
geometrie pauken bei monika schmidt
john kommt ins schwitzen die lehrerin
verteilt eine korrigierte prüfung
[Musik]
59 für john endlich einmal eine frohe
botschaft
eine frohe botschaft beabsichtigte auch
sonst stiefvater unter die leute zu
bringen als angehöriger einer freikirche
missioniert zur an sechs regelmäßig im
kiga kostüm auf der straße
ja die frohe botschaft evangelium muss
100 glück braucht werde ich das sage ich
ihre brüste
job des vertrages und hauptberuflich bin
ja vom gericht aber sagt lucia lied oder
aber gott hat gott hat uns versprochen
dass er neues versorgen
[Musik]
warum machst du so ein klamauk aus einer
ärzten sagte sie müssen nicht mich ernst
nehmen sie müssen die botschaft ernst
nehmen ich sage dir ernst gerade ja aber
ganz so voll ist da nicht immer
ende oktober bekommt schon die andere
seite seines stiefvaters zu spüren es
gab einen handgreiflichen streit nun
will der 16 jährige wieder einmal von zu
hause ausziehen
was ich den knall vor
diskussionen kann missverstanden ist und
auch alles auf eine karte
was das leck wieder
[Musik]
in diesem einfamilienhaus findet schon
für einige wochen unterschlupf hier ist
seine schul kollegin cindy dahin
[Musik]
er darf das gästezimmer beziehen
vielleicht ob für
das kein problem
das ist für ihn ist die deckung
john ist froh weg von zu hause zu sein
denn der streit war weit heftiger als er
offen zugibt sogar die polizei musste
einschreiten sein stiefvater wurde wegen
häuslicher gewalt aus der wohnung
gewiesen nachdem
zur an sechs hausverbot erhalten hatte
verbrachte er ferien in seinem
heimatland kroatien
nun ist er wieder in die eigenen vier
wände zurück gekehrt
sie sind polizeilich tag weg wie sie
wurden warum eigentlich die räuber wie
das metaphorisch dass ich die john sich
im zoo hannover haben und
schon hat das mag mode dann hat das
motto der polizei in der polizei und
dann ist das protokolliert wurde und
so wieck oder sie haben wir sofort weg
schon wieder dahin konflikt mit sich
selber eine sehr religiöse
politik wohltätige gegenüber dem
stiefsohn
sich das nicht so gut meine das
stichwort tätig
szene aus das szenario dir dass ich gar
nicht ein autorisierter farbkopien und
früchte jetzt einfach drauf los und
schon hast nichts motives motiv ist ja
dass ich gesehen dass sprache und
verbindlich sagen wir mal ab spricht
niedrig halten werde und dann
ist es so wie co dass sie halt einmal
immer häufiger kam oder mehrere häufiger
haben
[Musik]
saskia hat den geplatzten traum eine
sängerkarriere inzwischen verarbeitet
jetzt konzentriert sie sich auf einen
beruf der ihr auch gefällt
fachangestellte gesundheit
am ende der schnupper zeit im
kantonsspital baden hat stationsleiterin
priska villiger eine gute nachricht
[Musik]
stefan widmer schnuppert als
elektromonteur
nach einer woche auf dem bau folgt der
härtetest er muss eine prüfung ablegen
[Musik]
der chef persönlich prüft stefans arbeit
muss im boden ist keiner der lob im
überschuss verteilt
große show beziehe
damit auf die schenkel das eine gute
sache um oder auch sieht was
man jetzt
eingesetzte somit die ohren ich noch nie
so ganz im griff
dass die tröte zu
vermurkst sind von der zahl
ich gebe doch noch immer fehlen viele
die schnupperlehre hat ihm gut gefallen
doch stefan konnte zu wenige überzeugen
wochen später wird er eine absage
erhalten
im schulhaus niedermatten befindet im
spätherbst eine krisensitzung statt es
geht um john eingeladen sind seine
geschiedenen eltern mutter die elmar
seck allet und vater roger bürgi der zum
ersten mal an einem elterngespräch
teilnimmt mit dabei sind die lehrerinnen
der sozialarbeiter sowie schulleiterin
barbara plus
die schule ist mit johns verhalten nicht
zufrieden
ja ja aber so ganz wirklich da halt da
muss ich mich jetzt nicht und es wäre ja
eigentlich auch das bestreben jones
offenen lehrstellen finden
und autorschaft damit wirklich gut mit
wir wissen dass er auch er trifft will
trifft gar nicht möglich gut studieren
und der kopf brauchen
sie als eltern hat sie in kontrolliert
dann eigentlich sehr passiv gewesen die
bis zu
mein mann hat ein bisschen mehr drauf
gewartet
wobei die dinge die ich zuletzt erfahren
habe dass er gemacht hat als sind mit
wirklich erstaunt dass es so weit
gekommen ist john hat der mutter aber
noch nicht alles erzählt sie weiß zwar
dass ihr sohn mitten in der nacht auf
dem schulhausareal von einer
überwachungskamera gefilmt wurde doch
was er angestellt hat erfahren die
eltern erst jetzt
die schulleitung hat schon wegen
sachbeschädigung angezeigt
was macht der coach noch
er wird
und das ist nicht da was sie in die
fähigkeiten
die akkus dass die situation so
dramatisch ist alles paletti
sich eine besonders gute noten von denen
kein grund zur sorge ich muss allerdings
eine sage ich plane gerade sehr
komfortablen situation
die zweite frau informiert waren und
nicht nur problem sondern die umstände
hat kann richtige forderte ai und eine
weitere hertha setzt oder nicht wir die
letzte sache sieht man was man hat und
auch zu den steinbrüchen oder wenn ich
mit ihnen liegenden schiff alle zu sein
und wenn ich frage wo man später zur
schule gekommen ist dann geht es keine
richtige antwort
nicht befriedigend ist die zeit des
dunklen ab morgen zum 57 bürger zu leben
und arbeiten mag ich nicht
trotz alledem erhält schon noch eine
letzte chance er darf in der schule
bleiben vorausgesetzt er bessert sich
zuerst muss aber in ein timeout in einem
garten baugeschäft soll er sechs wochen
lang körperlich arbeiten
und wenn du damit nur gut bricht
referenz noch oft lehrstelle dax am
donnerstag
im klartext meine das nicht orientiert
wenn das nicht funktioniert dann kann
man ihn mit zurückzuholen ja
ich glaube es muss jetzt ein grosser ja
ich mache
[Musik]
ihren stil erzählt auch die freude sich
dann letztlich die schule
und wochen abschließen ich weiß schon
was machen
immer gut gemacht das ist rechtsaußen
zusammen
ich bin weg von 30
[Musik]
hallo
in ruhe
der nächste morgen
sozialarbeiter rossi frick bringt den
schülern ach wäre hart zu kuba der
besitzer eines garten unternehmens nimmt
immer wieder jugendliche bei sich auf
die in schwierigkeiten stecken
über wurde über das problem informiert
wurden wir nicht die welle und ich sehe
weiß ich sofort wohl dass ich bin und
wenn möglich dass und bin ich jetzt ganz
klar du hast du hast es ja keine angst
dass du da nicht rassismus novelle mal
die freunde und udo
john oder angie
die wir jetzt auf messen
um die saubere luft ruhm jetzt kann
studios als
ballettmeister austragen und precious
tor hinter denen ich schon vor durch
wird sich das ballett davor
dass manch einer schönen flandern
unterwegs
langguth gefahr dass besonders zu machen
oder und start der schule
aktiv
[Musik]
sprecht
prüfung haben willst du so wie es stefan
bei dieter weichselbraun von der
elektrofirma l und macht stefan eine
weitere schnupperlehre als elektriker
der 15 jährige steht auch hier unter
scharfer beobachtung der hydro galaxie
muss das
land hinter mir ist ein nachruf
wirklich denn seit das minus sei möglich
sind
außerdem machen wir damit hat das studio
sich lehrer ab nächstem august
was innenraum ist mit einer zusatz
fribourg ohne geld machen der däne steht
dass der notenschnitt stimmen
familientag bis zum letzten tag
wenn es nicht klappt wenn das nicht
erreicht werden denn die zwei varianten
das werkstoff des öfteren montage
elektriker oder durstig familienverein
ist
[Musik]
es ist kurz vor weihnachten die sechs
wochen timeout lägen hinter john nun
ketter zurück in die schule
[Musik]
der unterricht bei lukas grüninger
bin froh so will ich jedes mal so lange
schule war kann
und wir werden versuchen und konsumieren
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der lehrer hat alle hände voll zu tun um
die zügel in der hand zu behalten
ich brauche
was man für diese busse
abgestellt
was du gehören wie die auslöser ist
glaube ich auch geschafft
stefan
das brandneue state of the queen die
frau geschaffen
sodass es borgelt
[Musik]
susanne jumper liest das arbeitszeugnis
des gartenbau unternehmens
pünktlichkeit arbeitswille ausdauer
freundlichkeit und ehrlichkeit
und
super
gut gemacht gut gemacht autos
theoretischer
natur braucht sich nur um platz und sieg
auf der us-tour
nachfrage darf ist guten morgen herr
motivation war das stichwort
bei uns darf man da ist meine motivation
der stunde ist die neuen positiv die
mittagspause ist ja das positive antwort
ist er war sich jährlich das negative
ist
so wird er nicht sehr weit kommen dass
seine freche und zugleich die charmante
art kommt beim weiblichen geschlecht
sehr gut an
[Musik]
wesentlich kühler begrüßte cindy bei der
vorübergehend unterschlupf fand also zu
hause probleme hatte die beiden waren
für kurze zeit ein liebespaar das
sich
zurückziehen
sehr wichtig
sind die hat nebst ihrem liebeskummer
auch noch andere sorgen sie würde gerne
gestalterin in der werbetechnik werden
doch sie bekommt lauter absagen ihr
vater robert veres wünscht dass sich die
tochter auch für kaufmännische berufe
interessiert
ja und was jetzt
[Musik]
weil wir müssen wir ihnen mitteilen dass
sie ihre unterlagen nicht weiter
berücksichtigen können sich
interessenten mit noch treffen den
eigenschaften gemeldet haben
fantastisch ja
aber
das muss ich wieder nur geschrieben
[Musik]
elektronik
dietrich wenige folgen
pauli design
und aber klein ist und wieso plötzlich
auf polly designer bis ein dass es wohl
die grafen
skoda und peugeot ähnliches
regen importieren zu organisieren oder
zusammen
zielsichere sparte tesa mega schwedische
brater lehrstelle zu finden house steht
patricia und mit diesen die
kurzschließen und
grafiker wir machen das hat geklappt mit
dem kurs fordert
ob es sich alles ist unkompliziert sagt
vom jetzt
die zeit drängt denn es ist bereits ende
märz 2011 noch kein einziges mal hatte
john die gelegenheit eine schnupperlehre
zu machen im gegensatz zu seinen
klassenkameraden
fiona di benedetto schnuppert in einer
tierarztpraxis
doch die lehrstelle bekommt jemand
anders
dann macht sie in einem altersheim ein
praktikum
ich finds haben wir als das gefällt mir
sehr gut das team ist lässig die ganze
atmosphäre ist genial
[Musik]
fiona bekommt auf anhieb den lehrvertrag
der wunsch bruch von arnim die mini ist
logistiker problemlos erreicht er sein
ziel in einem großen industriebetrieb
darf er die ausbildung machen
hania heimann sucht noch immer eine
lehrstelle als medizinische
praxisassistentin aber auch für sie gibt
es eine lösung
sind die verfolgt doch noch den rat
ihres vaters und absolviert eine
kaufmännische schnupperlehre
es klappt beim ersten mal sie darf im
büro eines transportunternehmens die
lehre machen
wir sind stolz auf dich glaubt beziehung
ebenfalls grund zum feiern hat rafael
widmer auch er wird das kv machen
im april haben 16 schüler eine
lehrstelle gefunden drei werden das
zehnte schuljahr absolvieren nur für
einen gibt es immer noch keine lösung
für john seine motivation ist in jeder
hinsicht auf den nullpunkt gesunken
das wird dem 16 jährigen zum verhängnis
er und seine mutter sind nach dem
unterricht zu einem gespräch im zimmer
der schulleitung geladen
womit der abonnieren abwandeln
nervös weil ich sehr genau die situation
ist nicht einfach aber wir können die
aufnehmen du hast alle orte wo sie
hilfestellung abgelehnt
und was wir in diesen immer mehr
verzweifelte die hausaufgaben sind
eigentlich hauptsache nicht gemacht
wurde mode durchschnittlich immer dafür
aber kein großmaul
und
extrem schwer
fanden
die profis ist cannabis konsumiert
und das ist ganz klarer verstoß gegen
diese regel und war gegen die
schulregeln und digital konsequenzen und
sage nach das allerdings engagieren dort
ist leitung
eine medaille schon weg platz behalten
er beendet hatte er beendet nicht
und im prinzip hat man das schon lange
machen hat an dem ihr wehgetan wir haben
mehr braucht es mit presse
sondern sehen können
[Musik]
meine geschichte
inzwischen haben auch die anderen
erfahren was mit schon geschehen ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist nicht richtig ins spiel
die chancen sind unzählige chancen und
ich schaue nicht richtig ins centro will
mir eigentlich wenn wir ehrlich sind
wisse dass er acht im mythos steht
nach dem rauswurf verbrachte den tag mit
sich alleine erst am abend erzählt er
wie er die hiobsbotschaft der
schulleitung empfunden hat
sie gefährdeten mit dem gerechnet aber
was ich jetzt also wie sich und das
beste das man in dem sie so cool oder
durch nur so na ja ich hab's nicht
rechnung ich muss ich musste so
analytisch
machen sie sich vorwürfe versorgt zu
haben in der erziehung ja sehr oft habe
ich das gefunden das macht mich sehr
traurig immer wenn ich darüber nachdenke
aber was halten sie anders machen können
vielleicht wird zu hause seien einfach
zu hause seien für ihn da sein aber ich
musste arbeiten
um den unterhalt der familie zu
beschreiten
genau
[Musik]
außer den
ruf nicht dann verlängerung zu bieten
und wie gesagt pass auf dich auf
der jugendliche hat bis zum heutigen tag
keine lehrstelle gefunden
[Musik]
zur zeit geht so oft aus nicht zuletzt
um sich von seinen problemen abzulenken
doch der ernst des lebens hat für ihn
längst begonnen